this is the fifth annual puppies study
break it would started out with a group
of students who just wanted to make this
happen and they talked to a few Dean's
here and we put it together so it's a
partnership with administrators and
students
we're in John Jay lounge which is a dorm
a lounge in a dorm and it's the puppy
study break so people can come take a
break from their studies and play with
some dogs it is a study break that we
try to put on every semester here at
Columbia and basically we're just trying
to get people a little less stressed
finals can definitely be able
barrie stressful here and we're just
trying to let everyone have a good time
so there's dogs there's crafts there's
dining graciously provides drinks and
we're just trying to have a little fun
during finals the puppy study break is
so popular because of the dogs they get
so excited
hundreds of people friends the event but
even as I came down in the elevator
people were saying are you going to the
puppy study break they love it we came
to see the puppies yes basically this is
why I woke up this morning this is the
greatest way for people to relax
we know the human-animal bond is very
strong we know it changes the energy of
the room when an animal a dog is in the
room so the students walk in and all of
a sudden they're released with their
stress they calm down their blood
pressure actually is lower their heart
rate is lower the good endorphins come
out and they smile